[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
27 juni 1993 der Verfassungsschutz hat
einen V-Mann neben der meistgesuchten
Terroristen dieser Zeit platziert der in
der linken Szene bekannte Klaus
Steinmetz begleitet die 36-Jährige
raf-kämpferin Birgit Hogefeld auf
Schritt und Tritt er hat wohl sogar eine
Affäre mit ihr in Wahrheit aber
berichtet er alles was er mitbekommt der
Polizei als die Verfassungsschützer
hören das Steinmetz sich mit Birgit
Hogefeld in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
treffen will entschließt sich der
Generalbundesanwalt Alexander von Stahl
zum Zugriff in Wismar er gibt eine
spezialoperation in Auftrag die den
Decknamen Weinlese erhält über eine
Wanze hört der Einsatzleiter am
fraglichen Tag dann aber etwas sehr
interessant ist
irgendwo gefällt erwähnt dass sie heute
noch weitere Freunde treffen will und
zwar in Bad Kleinen also wird
kurzfristig entschieden die Verhaftung
sollen nicht in Wismar sondern eben dort
in Bad erfolgen die Aktion endet in
einem Debakel
und damit herzlich willkommen zum
zweiten Teil dieser unseligen Geschichte
mein Name ist Mirko Kasimir und ich bin
Toni Heyer hallo die rund 100 Polizisten
die für den Einsatz bereit stehen wollen
zwei Terroristen festnehmen zum Schein
natürlich auch den V-Mann Klaus
Steinmetz und sie wollen wissen ob in
einem Verdächtigen Opel auf dem
Bahnhofsvorplatz auch noch weitere
rf-touristen setzen und dann so
berichtet uns Bildreporter Frank
Schneider passiert die funk-panne und
hier war es so dass der Funkspruch
eigentlich lautete wenn Zugriff erfolgt
dann den Opel auf dem Bahnhofsvorplatz
kontrollieren weil man dachte da könnten
noch weitere Terroristen drin sitzen und
der Funkspruch der ankam bei dem Beamten
war eben ohne wenn Zugriff erfolgt Opel
am Bahnhofsvorplatz kontrollieren
der Beamte Michael nefzeller hört den
verstümmelten Funkspruch und macht sich
auf den Weg durch den Bahnhof zum Opel
dabei begegnet er für ihn völlig
überraschend kogefeld Steinmetz und
hogefelds Komplizen und
Ex-Lebensgefährten Wolfgang Grams die
drei kommen aus der Bahnhofsgaststätte
obwohl er verdutzt ist und wohl auch so
dreien blickt gelingt des nefzeller
Birgit vogelfeld zu überwältigen
Wolfgang Grams aber versucht zu
entkommen und schießt weil darauf sind
beide tot nefzeller und Grams der Beamte
wird im Bahnhof niedergeschossen der
Terrorist stirbt im Gleisbett was weiß
man über die Schüsse Bildreporter Peter
hell also was man weiß ist dass er Grams
auf der Flucht nach oben die Treppe sich
umgedreht hat und mehrfach gefeiert hat
dabei ist der Beamte getroffen worden
was man auch sagen muss damals wurden
keine schusswesten getragen es war
Sommer es war sehr warm es gab noch
keine flachen Westen wie heute die man
hätte vielleicht unter dem Hemd tragen
können und mit richtigen Westen werden
sie natürlich aufgefallen also die
Beamten waren schutzlos Krams ist nach
oben abgehauen hat sich umgedreht
geschossen und hat dabei eben diesen
Beamten den nämlich Zeller getroffen
tödlich dann später auch der ist im
Krankenhaus verstorben und dann bei
seiner Flucht ist hinter ihm her
geschossen worden bisher dann
schließlich ins Gleisbett gefallen ist
Birgit Hogefeld war fixiert am Boden wir
haben mit Beamten gesprochen vom BKA die
diesen Einsatz vorbereitet und begleitet
haben und die haben eben bemerkenswerte
Details auch gesagt dass roh gefällt
sich komplett widerstandslos hat
festnehmen lassen und dass sie auf dem
Boden gelegen hat und eine Beamtin sagte
sie hätte sich in die Hose gemacht vor
Angst also das sind Details die sind bis
dato auch noch nicht rausgekommen und
das war diese Beamtin Christa Bellmann
eine erfahrene BKA observantin die eben
in den Tagen vor dem Zugriff auch noch
die Aufgabe hatte Klaus Steinmetz den
Baumann zu begleiten zu observieren er
wusste nichts davon weil man Angst hatte
klausteinmetz der Frau man kam ja aus
der linken Szene aus der Wiesbadener
Szene aus der linksextremistischen Szene
die haben ihn ja dort rekrutiert und
Christa Bellmann hatte die Aufgabe ihn
zu observieren zu begleiten auch bei
diesen verschiedenen Treffen bei den
Einsatzorten wo sie waren ja vier Tage
vorher schon mal in Bad klein damit er
nicht abspringt weil man vermutet hatte
dass Klaus Steinmetz ein falsches Spiel
spielt oder vielleicht sogar gefällt
warnt oder vielleicht sogar den ganzen
Einsatz zerstören könnte deswegen hatte
man ihm auch nichts gesagt und hatte
eben Christa Bellmann ihm an die Seite
gestellt die sich eben als
ältere Dame schon vier Tage vorher mit
ihm ins hochgesetzt hat in einem
Blümchen Kleid völlig unauffällig und
Steinmetz war ja ausgerüstet das wusste
er auch nicht in seinem Laptop war ein
Mikrofon und ein GPS-Sender wo man immer
wusste wo er war
aus dem super schon vorbereiteten
Einsatz ist ein einziges Blutbad
geworden ein Beamter ist ums Leben
gekommen und ein Terrorist starb und
kann nicht mehr zur Rechenschaft gezogen
werden aber wie genau kam Wolfgang Grams
ums Leben er wird auf der Flucht
mehrfach getroffen er stürzt rücklings
auf das Gleis und bleibt dort liegen er
stirbt noch offiziellen Angaben an einem
Nachschuss in die Schläfe schnell
verkündet das Bundeskriminalamt es habe
sich um Selbstmord gehandelt aber eine
Kioskverkäuferin auf dem Bahnsteig will
gesehen haben dass die Beamten aus
nächster Nähe auf gramsossen ein
anonymer Polizeibeamter berichtet dem
Spiegel von einem gezielten Nachschuss
der GSG 9 Männer aufgabens außerdem hat
offenbar keiner von den vielen
Polizisten vor Ort wirklich gesehen die
graben sich selber erschossen
im Gegenteil die GSG 9-männer die ihn
verfolgten wollen Grams in den
entscheidenden Sekunden nicht im
Blickfeld gehabt haben das Drama von Bad
Kleinen beherrscht wochenlang die
Schlagzeilen nicht nur der Tod von Krams
sorgt für Widersprüche auch der Einsatz
des V-Mannes wird öffentlich diskutiert
und auch wenn sich eine absichtliche
Tötung des Terroristen nie beweisen
lässt der politische Schaden ist riesig
genug
Ärger also und wie Bildreporter Peter
hält zusammen fast laufen dann auch noch
die Ermittlungen richtig daneben naja
wie es bei solchen sogenannten kann
einsetzen häufiger der Fall ist gibt es
natürlich auch bei der Aufarbeitung
Probleme es gab im Nachhinein furchtbare
Fehler die erkannt worden sind bei der
Spurensicherung es sind erst Spuren
teilweise Wochen später reserviert
worden dass sie Kugeln gefunden haben
erst im Gleisfeld es wurden
katastrophale Fehler gemacht z.B
Wolfgang Grams als er in die
Gerichtsmedizin kam da hat man seine
Einschusswunde gereinigt die Haare
abrasiert also so konnte man überhaupt
keine stanzmarke feststellen das ist der
Schusskanal in der die Pistole an den
Kopf falls sich die Pistole an den Kopf
gesetzt hat hätte man das feststellen
können man hat seine Hände gewaschen
also es gab auch keine Spurenlage was
die Fingerabdrücke anbelangt es gab
natürlich eine politische
Auseinandersetzung ein Chaos innerhalb
der Regierung im Zuge dessen auch der
damalige Innenminister rudolf-seiters
zurücktreten musste nach einer Woche
oder nicht musste sondern er hat
freiwillig den Hut genommen auch der
Generalbundesanwalt Alexander von Stahl
weil sie die Vorwürfe gegenseitig
gehäuft haben und die Presse sehr stark
medial Druck gemacht hat weil es eben
anfangs hieß Grams sei erschossen worden
von GSG9 Beamten und das wäre ein
einmaliger Vorgang überhaupt in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland gewesen das
Beamte quasi ein Terroristen
hingerichtet hätten regelrecht und das
ist eben komplett aus dem Ruder gelaufen
und dann wurde gebacken eben als Synonym
gehandelt als Chaos Einsatz auf Kosten
der Polizei
Bundesinnenminister Seiters von der CDU
übersteht das Chaos also nichts und
tritt schließlich zurück wie der NDR in
einer guten Zusammenfassung ergänzt
geraten auch völlig unschuldige in den
politischen Zwist so müssen die Eltern
des getöteten Beamten nefzeller
jahrelang mit Anfeindungen aus der
linken Szene Leben
Aktivisten drohen damit den Leichnam des
Polizisten auszugraben und auf den Müll
zu werfen ihr Sohn wird zudem immer im
gleichen Atemzug mit dem
Terrorverdächtigen genannt man muss aber
auch sagen dass die RF und ihre
Unterstützer völlig geschockt sind nicht
nur vom Tod des Wolfgang Grams sondern
vom Umstand dass der vermeintliche
Kamerad Klaus Steinmetz ein Spitzel war
aus Sicht der Terrorbande ein Verräter
dieser Erkenntnis dämmerte ihn aber nur
ganz langsam Frank Schneider deshalb war
dieser Verrat durch diesen V-Mann auch
so unglaublich schlimm für die linke
Szene weil das überhaupt einer so nah
dran war und man ihm vertraut hat und
wie gesagt wahrscheinlich hohe fällt
sogar ein intimes Verhältnis mit ihm
hatte dass er sie dann am Ende verraten
hat dass die ersten Tage nach dem
Zugriff bei kleinen dachte man noch er
wäre abgehauen hätte noch flüchten
können man hat sogar sich mit seinen
Eltern in Verbindung gesetzt man wollte
ihm helfen aber nach wenigen Tagen ist
dann klar gewesen er hängt damit drin
und lebt wie gesagt bis heute im
Zeugenschutz wir haben ja mit vielen
sprechen können die damals beteiligt
waren ob es Verfassungsschutz war BKA
hochspannende Einblicke bekommen aber da
wollte keiner darüber sprechen was es
heute wirklich mit dem Farmer ich hatte
aber auch das Gefühl das wissen viele
nicht das war am Ende sogar Heim das
heißt wusste nur ganz wenige Person wo
ist der wie heißt der was macht der
heute das dient natürlich auch seiner
Sicherheit die waren Umstände sprachen
sich erst später rum wie Peter hell
betont Klaus Steinmetz nach der
Festnahme auf wundersame Weise natürlich
vom Verfassungsschutz in Sicherheit
gebracht worden anfänglich hat die RAF
gar nicht damit gerechnet dass es sich
dabei um einen Spitzel handelt man hat
dann nach zwei drei Wochen ungefähr
Verdacht geschöpft hat dann sich in der
Szene gewarnt man hat ein Suchzettel ein
Fahndungsaufruf gemacht die Rote Hilfe
also auch Sympathisanten der RF mit der
Warnung Achtung wer kannte Klaus seit
vorsichtig wenn ihr ihn seht sagt sofort
Bescheid Klaus Steinmetz ist dann vom
Verfassungsschutz legendiert worden er
ist wahrscheinlich in den Zeugenschutz
gekommen hat einen neuen Namen wir
vermuten das ja im Ausland lebt eine
neue Identität angenommen hat und es
gibt keinerlei Informationen weitere
über ihn der gezogen ist mittlerweile
auf freiem Fuß sie ist
1994 zu lebenslange Haft verurteilt
worden man weiß auch nicht so richtig wo
sie sich aufhält sie wird auch unter
einem neuen Namen wahrscheinlich leben
sie hat sich aber auch nie genau dazu
eingelassen wie was wo gemacht worden
ist das ist übrigens eine sehr spannende
Geschichte über die Täter der Raff sie
haben sich nie nie gegenseitig verraten
es gab wohl treffen wo sie eine Abkommen
geschlossen haben dass wenn irgendeiner
festgenommen wird dass nie gesagt wird
wer ist der Täter von Schleier wer ist
der Täter von ponto wer ist der Täter
von Bubak wer könnte der Täter von
Herrhausen gewesen sein es wird nie
gesagt und daran halten sie sich heute
auch noch fassen wir also noch mal
zusammen Klaus Steinmetz lebt unter
falschem Namen und Polizeischutz bis
heute im Ausland Birgit Hogefeld wurde
im November 1996 vom Oberlandesgericht
Frankfurt am Main wegen Mordes
versuchten Mordes und Mitgliedschaft in
einer terroristischen Vereinigung zu
einer lebenslangen Freiheitsstrafe
verurteilt im Juni 2011 wurde sie als
letztes inhaftiertes RAF Mitglied aus
der Haft entlassen fünf Jahre nach dem
Debakel bei der Operation Weinlese endet
die Zeit des rf-terrors in Deutschland
am 20 April 1998 geht bei der
Nachrichtenagentur Reuters in Köln ein
Schreiben ein in dem die RF ihre
Selbstauflösung verkündet darin heißt es
vor fast 28 Jahren am 14 mai 1970
entstand in einer Befreiungsaktion die
RAF heute beenden wir dieses Projekt die
Stadt gerial in Form der RAF ist nun
Geschichte wir das sind alle die bis
zuletzt in der RAF organisiert gewesen
sind wir tragen diesen Schritt gemeinsam
ab jetzt sind wir wie alle anderen aus
diesem Zusammenhang ehemalige militante
der RF wir stehen zu unserer Geschichte
die RAF war der revolutionäre Versuch
einer Minderheit entgegen der Tendenz
dieser Gesellschaft zur Umwälzung der
kapitalistischen Verhältnisse
beizutragen
wir sind froh Teil dieses Versuchs
gewesen zu sein
das Ende dieses Projekts zeigt dass wir
auf diesem Weg nicht durchkommen konnten
aber es spricht nicht gegen die
Notwendigkeit und Legitimation der
wollte aber auch wenn jetzt der
Perspektive Terror der RF vorbei war da
blieben trotzdem viele Fragen zum
Beispiel nach der Beteiligung der DDR am
linken terror- und Westdeutschland und
wie Bildreporter Frank Schneider
ebenfalls davor hebt sind ja bis heute
noch Terroristen unerkannt auf freiem
Fuß man muss vielleicht noch dazu sagen
das ist ganz spannend weil in der DDR
wurden ja auch RAF Terroristen versteckt
und das heißt die Stasi hat halt zu
DDR-Zeiten noch über Material verfügt
von den Terroristen das heißt dieses
Haar was von Grams gefunden wurde am
Tatort an dem Handtuch könnte
möglicherweise dort bewusst platziert
worden sein um es ihn in die Schuhe zu
schieben also das ist bis heute Abend
das kann man nicht mehr Fragen er ist
bei diesem Einsatz ins Leben gekommen
aber es gibt bis heute berechtigte
Zweifel das überhaupt keine
Verschwörungstheorie sondern dass es
möglicherweise gerade bei den
Tötungsdelikten an Herrhausen und auch
an rohwerder möglicherweise doch andere
Gründe gibt es gab aber dann noch einen
Anschlag einen Bombenanschlag auf den
noch nicht eröffneten Knast in
Weiterstadt eine riesengroße J da die da
gebaut worden war und dabei ist ein
immenser Schaden entstanden aber nur
Sachschaden das hat man auch noch dieser
dritten Generation zugeordnet und danach
ist eigentlich Ruhe eingekehrt was aber
hoch spannend ist aber von dem Opel
erzählt auf dem Bahnhofsvorplatz
womöglicherweise noch weitere
Terroristen der dritten Generation drin
saßen und heute sind immer noch drei
Terroristen der dritten Generation auf
der Flucht garweg Staub und Klette und
diese drei sind die die auch als
sogenannte raf-rentner Geldtransporter
überfallener mit Panzerfäusten und wie
will man ihn jetzt genau zuordnen kann
ist immer so eine Frage gewesen das war
irgendwas zwischen zwei und fünf genau
weiß man es nicht aber man hatte mal das
Gefühl die lebendig weiter im Untergrund
die müssen ihr Leben irgendwie
finanzieren und haben das mit
spektakulären Überfällen jetzt ist
längere Zeit Ruhe wo sie wirklich leben
es war mal der Verdacht möglicherweise
in Benelux also Holland Belgien oder in
Frankreich manchmal ist auch vielleicht
doch Richtung Spanien dann hieß sie
hätten hier immer noch so eine Art
Bunker Wohnung wo sie für Straftaten
zurückkehren und zwar im Bereich
Niedersachsen Mecklenburg -vorpommern
das war ja damals eben auch schon mit
den Zugriff bei kleinen war auch
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern diese Region ist
halt dünn besiedel da fällt man nicht
auf also genau weiß man das bis heute
nicht es bleibt also immer noch so
letzte Rätsel und Zweifel bleiben
eigentlich bis heute und auch selbst
wenn man die drei heute kriegen würden
ich glaube auch sie würden sie sprechen
halt nicht mit dem Rechtsstaat sie
würden auch zu diesen ganzen Dingen
wahrscheinlich nichts mehr sagen
eines Tages wird sich vielleicht auch
noch das Rätsel um die rauben den
raf-rentner lösen aber für heute sind
wir am Ende wir haben die Geschehnisse
rund um die Operation Weinlese aus dem
Archiv des Axel Springer Verlages und
mit der Hilfe von Frank Schneider und
Peter hellr recherchiert geholfen hat
uns auch eine Chronik des NDR die Links
dazu findet ihr in den shonos Aufnahme
und schnitt Toni Hayer Skript Stefan
Netzeband Postproduktion durch wakeword
München schön dass ihr heute wieder mit
dabei wart bis zum nächsten mal eure
Toni und euer Mirko